I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I'm the one history to
repeat itself Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle are offering an unfiltered look
into their personal lives in the new
Netflix docu series Harry and Megan yep
the highly anticipated series officially
premiered overnight with the first three
episodes giving viewers the most
intimate picture yet of the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex I just really want to
get to the other side of all of this I
don't know what to say anymore
featuring never before seen personal
archival footage the royal family is
bracing itself for Revelations from the
series but Netflix notes at the
beginning of the first episode that the
royal family declined to comment on the
content within this series meanwhile
viewers get a closer look on how the
couple first met their first dates
together and why they decided to step
back as senior Royals and work to become
financially independent back in 2020 and
just like many romantic connections
Harry and Megan first met over Instagram
thanks to a mutual friend
I was scrolling through my feed and uh
someone who was a friend had this video
of the two of them's like a Snapchat oh
gosh that whole thing it starts like
doggies that's what he saw of me
that was the first thing I was like who
is that and then she sent me an email
saying I know you said you're single and
a friend of mine asked about you and
maybe you'd like to meet him and I said
who is it and she said it's Prince has
and I said who's that
[Music]
I asked if I could see his feed yes
Harry's private Instagram account is
revealed in the new series which
features lots of wildlife photography
something that clearly impressed Megan
as they exchanged phone numbers and
agreed to meet up in London shortly
after discovering each other on the
social media platform
[Music]
we met at 76th Street they were late and
I couldn't understand why he would be
late that he kept texting when he was
like he's coming in traffic I'm so sorry
I'm in traffic I'm so sorry
I was panicking I was freaking out I was
so sweating
again I didn't know him so I was like oh
is is this what he does got it like this
I'm not doing nothing what was that
supposed to be like one of the guys
who's so much of an ego that you're not
gonna that you don't that any girl would
sit around and wait for a half hour for
you as for Megan's first impression when
Harry finally made it to their first
date he was just so
fun
just so refreshingly fun and that was
the thing we were like childlike
together there was one photo we just
wanted to capture the feeling of just
sitting in that little restaurant and
going oh my gosh I think we're gonna
give it a go and the rest is history
Megan and Harry also offered insight
into their family life in Montecito
California as they share glimpses of
their three-year-old son Archie
including photos from what appears to be
Archie's first birthday look at that
how would you describe it Archie look at
all those beautiful
Mama because I visit you
Switching gears in episode two the
sussexes are seen being followed by a
photographer with Harry comparing
Paparazzi following Diana to the online
harassment faced by Megan back in my
mum's day is
was physical harassment you know cameras
in your face
following you chasing you Paparazzi
still harass people
but the harassment really exists more
online now
once the photographs are out in the
stories then put next to it then comes
the social media harassment
who I love go through this feeling
frenzy that's hard the couple also
recalled Megan's first meeting with
Queen Elizabeth II revealing how it was
a shock for Megan my grandmother was the
first senior member of the family that
Megan Matt she had no idea what it all
consisted of
so it was a bit of a it was a bit of a
shock to this it was a bit of a shock to
the system for her I didn't know I was
going to meet her until moments before
now I'm starting to realize this is a
big deal I mean Americans will
understand this we have Medieval Times
dinner and tournament it was like that
like I curtsied as though I was like
[Music]
pleasure to meet you your majesty